[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
about an hour from right now and we'll
carry it live joe biden will deliver his
first address to a joint session of
congress
he'll be making his way from the white
house to the capitol shortly
now the early excerpts the short ones
we've seen of this speech amount in
effect to a mushy
casserole of cliches they're designed to
calm your suspicions that anything
weird or scary might be going on in the
country and to reassure you that
everything's going to be fine
just fine in fact better than it was
in that way it has the same narcotic
intent
of the biden campaign itself remember
that don't worry
we're moderates we'll make everything
normal again
whatever you think of joe biden that
turned out to be one of the greatest
lies ever told
in four months this white house has
changed america more quickly and more
radically than any before it
they have moved so fast and with such
stunning aggression that even people who
are paid to keep track of it like us
can barely keep up every change they
have forced has moved the country in the
very same direction
away from democracy where every voter
has the same power
as a voter and towards something very
different
toward tyranny most ominous of all and
this is the hallmark of tyranny
they have not hesitated to use the force
of law to punish their political
opponents
here's the latest example and it may be
the scariest at six am this morning
federal agents raided the home of former
new york city mayor rudy giuliani
they seized his personal property
including his electronic devices
which include all of his digital
communications and records
before they did this the feds notified
their allies that the democratic party's
campaign
operation the lincoln project the
lincoln project then bragged online that
they knew
this raid was coming now you may have
thought the lincoln project was
done we told you that in fact we
believed it was permanently discredited
by a child molestation scandal which
they admitted
but it wasn't under this administration
the lincoln project is stronger than
ever strong enough to know about an fbi
raid before it happens
and of course it's stronger because the
lincoln project is an ally of the white
house and so by definition
they can do whatever they want and they
do but rudy giuliani is not a political
ally of the white house in fact he was
the
personal attorney of the former
president whose communications by the
way the feds are of course reading right
now tonight as we speak
and in the end that was giuliani's core
offense being trump's lawyer
that and having the gall to try to learn
more about what exactly joe biden and
his son were doing in ukraine
several years ago the justice department
announced today that asking too many
questions about the biden's dealings in
ukraine is effectively a crime they
called it something else but that's what
giuliani did
what's interesting is the one electronic
device the feds didn't seize the fbi did
not take in today's raid
was a copy of hunter biden's hard drive
from his laptop
giuliani had a copy of that in his
apartment at one point
agents picked it up and looked at it but
when giuliani told them where it came
from that it came from hunter biden
they put it down and they left it there
it was the one thing they didn't want
and that's very strange if you think
about it the justice department is now
telling us that giuliani was somehow
involved in foreign tampering with our
democracy
russia by implication was involved so
you'd think they'd want to examine rudy
giuliani's
own copy of hunter biden's laptop
why because hunter biden himself just
told us on television
that that laptop that hard drive could
be tied directly to russian intelligence
you know the fake russian laptop with
all the photoshopped pictures of hunter
biden smoking fake russian crack
with those fake russian hookers so why
wouldn't the fbi want to see rudy
giuliani's own copy of that
well you'd think they would because as
joe biden told us during the october
debate on tv
joe biden himself believed that rudy
giuliani was a pawn
of russian intelligence we are in a
situation where we have foreign company
countries trying to interfere in the
outcome of our election
his old own national security adviser
told him that
what is happening with his buddy well i
won't i shouldn't well
i will his buddy rudy giuliani he's
being used as a russian
pawn he's being fed information that is
russian
that is not true always being
fed information by the russians by
russian intelligence by vladimir putin
so if rudy giuliani was working for the
russian government as the now president
of the united states claimed in public
you would think
biden's justice department would want
all the russia related
evidence it could get from rudy
giuliani's apartment oh but they didn't
that's not what they wanted
instead they told giuliani they had a
search warrant for all communications
between him and among others
a journalist called john solomon if the
name sounds familiar john solomon
often appears in sean hannity's hour
right after this one so why are they
interested in john solomon well we don't
know but here's a guess
at one point john solomon's reporting
uncovered the fact that a key figure in
the mueller investigation
ukrainian businessman called constantin
kilmannic
was in fact an informant for the u.s
government
now that was an essential fact to know
but robert mueller did not disclose it
in his final report
instead he portrayed the ukrainian as a
russian
agent now that was a lie it was a lie by
omission
and that lie helped prop up the whole
collusion hoax
john solomon exposed that lie
and it looks like the biden people
haven't forgotten about it
now the fbi's pretext for investigating
giuliani all these things have a pretext
is that he violated something that no
one in america even heard of a few years
ago called pharah that's the foreign
agents registration act it's been on an
awful long time for 50 years a total of
seven people face criminal charges for
violating farah
only one was convicted in fact the u.s
attorney's manual at the department of
justice
said that you should warn lobbyists who
don't comply with pharaoh
not prosecute them warn them most
violations were ignored in fact they
still
are ignored it's extremely common in
washington and it's not russia that
people are lobbying for
but they're treated as civil matters
that all changed when donald trump was
elected fair investigations became a
tool that the doj
used against mouthy and inconvenient
republicans
there have been more fera prosecutions
in the past three years than we've seen
over the past half century
these are process crimes and they've
been weaponized against
political opponents political opponents
of permanent washington
and particularly of the bide
administration roger stone would know
he's got a phd in that subject
roger stone has never been elected to
anything and you could argue he's never
wielded profound
political power but he has been a long
time informal advisor of donald trump
and in 2019
for that crime roger stone was arrested
on the grounds that he'd lied to
congress
about a subject that honestly no one now
can seem to remember what were the
details nobody knows it was that
insignificant
and by the way the context is this lying
to congress
it happens all the time like roughly
every day and sometimes it gravely hurts
the country james clapper for example he
was the former director of national
intelligence
and he lied to congress when he said
that the nsa was not spying on millions
of americans the nsa was
in violation of our constitutional
rights he committed perjury
no problem brennan the former cia
director
lied when he said the cia wasn't spying
on the u.s senate can you imagine an
intel agency
spying on the legislative branch that
was happening he lied about it
another case of perjury and yet here's
the interesting thing neither clapper
and brennan was ever prosecuted for
perjury in fact
both got better jobs you can see them on
tv tonight collecting their paychecks
from the networks
why do they get off because they're on
the right side
roger stone by contrast advised donald
trump and here's what happened to him
exclusive footage you're looking at
right now from cnn as the fbi
arrives at roger stone's residence in
fort lauderdale florida
taking him into custody they arrived
before
dawn there before 6a or just after 6 a.m
a dozen officers were told
a cnn exclusive well cnn was tipped off
to that raid
before it happens imagine a country in
which the department of justice men with
guns who can literally
shoot you and get away with it use the
american
news media for political purposes to
hurt you before you've even been put on
trial
that's corrupt and what you just saw on
television that clip that's one of the
most grotesque displays of corrupt
justice to happen in this country in our
lifetime
in the end roger stone got a
presidential pardon in the final moments
of the trump
administration but the story wasn't over
for him the harassment
continued the biden administration has
now announced that they are suing roger
stone for non-payment of interest and
penalties on his taxes
he's paid the taxes not an easy thing
when his prosecution left him unable to
work
when the judge in the case said he
couldn't even speak in public he was
completely broke
stone paid everything he owed he was
negotiating a settlement
for the penalties and the interest he
was negotiating with the government
as many do and then the day after joe
biden was inaugurated
the feds pulled out of the negotiation
and went after him publicly and sued him
rogerstone is broke they've wrecked his
life
but guess who's doing great these days
can you guess hunter biden
and it turns out that hunter biden has
tax problems too we know that from his
laptop it indicated that he may have
taken
millions of dollars from communist party
officials in china
the question is did hunter biden pay
taxes on that money
the justice department at one point was
wondering that too they had a criminal
investigation into hunter biden's tax
question
but you haven't heard a lot about that
investigation lately have you that's
weird
or maybe it's not so weird because on
inauguration day joe biden named a new
head
of the criminal division of the
department of justice that man is called
nicholas mcquaid and it just so happens
he was a law partner
of hunter biden's defense attorney for
years
funny how that works under mcquaid's
leadership
the feds have become more aggressive
than ever in using the force of law to
crush political dissent
in the leaks to the media for example
the feds announced they were
investigating congressman mack gates of
florida for the crime of sex trafficking
you could read it about in the new york
times they told the new york times which
dutifully wrote an entire piece about it
that piece essentially destroyed matt
gates it took him completely off the map
as a rhetorical force
whatever his flaws may be matt gates is
smart
he's articulate and he's brave matt
gates was one of the very few members in
the entire congress who bothered to
stand
up against permanent washington on
behalf of his constituents
but you're not hearing much of him now
because matt gates is a sex trafficker
so the question is who exactly did
matt's gates sex traffic
well we can't answer that question
because no charges have been filed
so all that remains is the stigma
the remarkable thing is and we're almost
getting tired of these contrasts but
here's the most vivid
there is apparently material on hunter
biden's laptop that suggests hunter
biden was involved in the sexual abuse
of minors
now if that's so the fbi would know it
of course because they have a copy of
the laptop and yet here's the funny
thing
no one has leaked anything about this to
the new york times or politico
or nbc news hunter biden has not been
charged with this not with sex abuse he
hasn't been charged with the federal
firearms felony that he committed we can
say that conclusively
he lied on a background check he
committed a felony a federal firearms
felony
so is he going to jail oh no he's
thriving hunter biden got a million
dollar
book contract multi-millions we have
read from simon schuster and then he got
a gig
teaching at tulane so it's good to be
the president's son
you know it's not good to be it's not
good to be a trump voter that's very
clear now
watch this partisan federal prosecutor
man who's completely out of control
explain on television
that republicans are so much as
trespassed at the capitol on january 6th
will be traded like al qaeda
after the six we had an inauguration on
the 20th so
i wanted to ensure and our office wanted
to ensure that there was shock and awe
that we could charge
as many people as possible before the
20th and
it worked because we saw through media
posts
that people were afraid to come back to
dc because they're like if we go there
we're going to get charged
we wanted to take out those individuals
that essentially were thumbing their
noses
at the the public for what they did okay
that guy's a lunatic he should not have
power but more to the point what he just
said
is the opposite of justice in a
just system you punish people for the
crimes they
committed equally with everyone else who
has committed those crimes
you don't punish some people extra to
send a political point
or to deter future behavior that might
inconvenience a political party or to
stop a dissent
and that's exactly what he did that's
not legal by the way a district court
judge christopher cooper just released
one man who has been in detention for
four months now that man a 60 year old
named richard barnett had made the
mistake of entering nancy pelosi's
office without permission
he didn't burn it down he didn't hurt
anybody but for that crime for
trespassing in nancy pelosi's office
he was locked away in solitary
confinement there he was allegedly
beaten by prison guards
including a guard who told him that he
hated all white people now judge cooper
who we should tell you is an obama
appointee
had to inform the department of justice
this week that richard barnett though
you may not like who he voted for
still has rights in a constitutional
democracy and so barnett was finally
released from jail
thanks to the judge but that case was
not unusual
barnett was one of more than 36
protesters from january 6 who have been
held in solitary confinement at a dc
jail for months now this is so
disproportionate especially considering
the people who torch buildings including
federal buildings and rape others
and commit gun crimes and rape are
getting out of prison in a day
this is such egregious treatment that
democrats in the senate were including
real lefties like dick durbin and
elizabeth warren actually said something
about it quote
solitary confinement is a form of
punishment that is cruel and
psychologically damaging elizabeth
warren said elizabeth warren
and we're talking about people who
haven't been convicted of anything yet
well thank you elizabeth warren
you may be wrong on everything but
you're right on that and bless you for
saying so
in a functioning democracy every member
of the democratic party would be saying
exactly the same thing republicans would
be saying it too where are the
republicans by the way what does mitch
mcconnell do for a living
hasn't said much about this they've been
silent about this egregious abuse of
human rights
in a functioning democracy that cared
about justice there would be demands for
the immediate release
of every non-violent protester who went
to the capitol on january 6th
but there aren't so the white house will
likely lock up more people it disagrees
with just today we should tell you
victoria tensing has been a guest on
this show many times
former federal prosecutor a serious
person an attorney of 50 years in the
district of columbia
had her home raided by federal agents
and her electronic devices seized
why we'll tell you when we know